es un día soleado en la isla de la
reunión pero nuevas restricciones entran
en vigor residentes y turistas de este
territorio francés deberán respetar el
toque de queda de las nueve de la noche
hasta las cinco de la mañana una medida
que viene después de que la isla decretó
el estado de emergencia sanitaria
concediendo a las autoridades locales el
derecho a imponer nuevas restricciones
para contener la propagación del vivos
es un poco triste porque nos decimos
porque ellos mientras que nosotros en
francia continental seguimos viviendo
como si todo estuviera normal
adicionalmente al toque de queda todas
las reuniones en los espacios públicos
fueron prohibidas restaurantes bares
cines librerías así como los centros
deportivos podrán abrir solamente para
el 75 por ciento del aforo máximo los
comerciantes también están preocupados
por el impacto que podría tener en sus
industrias a beckham hay que decirlo con
el toque de queda a las nueve de la
noche tendremos una hora y media de
servicio y la gente no va a salir para
eso a las 9 tienen que estar en casa ya
lo experimentamos en el pasado cuando
tuvimos hasta 70% menos de ventas en la
noche
el 29 de diciembre pasado la tasa de
contagios alcanzó
946 casos por cada 100.000 personas en
la isla según las autoridades las cifras
son preocupantes ya que es el mayor
índice desde el inicio de la pandemia